hello guys and girls raj here back with
another video
so kubernetes is super hot right now in
job market
so in this video we are going to go over
some kubernetes interview questions and
answers
uh i have given timestamps with the
video for your viewing convenience
so let's jump into it so the questions
we are going to cover is
how do you automate kubernetes
deployment
how do you secure kubernetes application
how do you cost or performance optimize
kubernetes app
tell me about a challenge you face in
kubernetes application
how do you scale kubernetes
and how do you expose a kubernetes
microservice to consumers
and do you have to use kubernetes uh to
run your containerized app for each of
these questions i'm going to give you
like a real-world tip
that you can say that so the interview
interviewer will understand that you
actually worked in kubernetes and not
just uh learn from theory
uh so what about the basic questions uh
like
what is kubernetes what is content
orchestrator
etc
so for those i'm gonna give some video
links in the description check them out
for those basic questions
with that being said let's jump into
question number one so first question is
how do you automate kubernetes
deployment
uh so the important thing to realize
here is to understand the devops flow
for kubernetes
uh so let's say developer checks in the
application code into the code
repository
and then somehow you have to dockerize
that application code
create a container image and put that
container image into a container emails
repository
from there you have to deploy the
container image at a kubernetes cluster
where the image will run as a container
the first part is called the build and
the next part is called deploy
so keeping this in mind
what you need to do is
let's say you put your code in the git
such as code repo as in github
now you need to
have a tool where you can run commands
because if you think about it at the end
of the day
when you say you dockerize something all
you are doing is running your docker
file right so you need a tool that will
allow you to run
those commands
after that you save the container image
into the container image repository
and for deployment again
you need another tool to run commands
so how do you deploy into kubernetes
cluster
so either you use a helm or you can use
direct commands like cube ctl apply
right
so on the deploy phase as well you need
a mechanism which will allow you to run
this
so if you transform these requirements
into actual stack
so how it would look like is
a developer putting code into code repo
such as git
and then you need
tools like either jenkins code build or
gitlab which will allow you to dockerize
it
after you put it
put the container image into the
repository again you can use jenkins
code build gitlab
which will let you run helm commands or
cube ctrl commands to deploy into
kubernetes cluster
so this is the high level flow
if you understand this flow you can
implement any kubernetes devops
i have a separate video on eks how to
implement a ci cd with eks uh so feel
free to check that out i'll give the
link up top
okay moving on to the next question
how do you secure kubernetes application
so when it comes to security there are
two aspects for kubernetes security
one is the security of your application
running on the cluster
and the other is
devsecops so basically devops plus
security
security of the container devops
lifecycle
so for the application security
uh you secure your pod namespace node
using role-based access control irsa etc
so i have a this is a big topic the
application security
so i have a separate video on this i'll
give it up top the link as well feel
free to check it out
it is super important that you
understand this rbac and irsa for any
interviews or real world applications
next is the security of the devops
so the first thing is authorization
what i mean by that is you need to
enforce that im user or role uh has
proper authorization to run your devops
cycle
like if a project a is trying to
deploy something for project b it should
be stopped right so for aws you can you
you can utilize iam for this
next is
scanning
um the container images for
vulnerability
so there are multiple ways to do this
so there are different tools like sysdig
falco to do this if you are using
elastic container registry on aws uh aws
released a feature where you can scan
the images for vulnerability for free of
charge
and next is once your container image is
running as container you can also keep
scanning those
there are multiple tools available such
as twist lock etc that you can utilize
so again uh
for interviews you have to keep your
answers succinct right so make sure you
hit these two points like hey
there are two aspects to it application
depth checkups and then
give like a little bit of description
and then interviewer will probably if
they want to go deep they will ask
questions on our back irs etc and then
you can
go super granular
and on top of that there is another uh
factor for security one is the security
compliance that your application needs
uh so if you are if your application is
highly secure and it requires uh federal
compliance hipaa sock etc
so you can mention that hey
maybe if you're running in a blue s if
you need fedramp high
run it in golf cloud
keep in mind some of the things like
amazon ecs is fair drum high compliant
eks is federal moderate etc so this last
part is kind of real world
if you just learn theory you can talk
about application and dev checkouts but
the security compliance thing
most of the people probably won't
mention
okay moving on a super important topic
how do you cost or performance optimize
kubernetes application
so when it comes to kubernetes cost the
first component is control plane cost
however for good or bad this cost is
fixed
let's say for example eks you pay 10
cents per hour
it scales automatically and the and the
right is fixed so there is not much room
for improvement most of your kubernetes
cost
will come from
your worker node number of worker nodes
and the types of worker nodes right
so how does the number of worker nodes
gets chosen
so basically when you define your
container image in a pod spec
you will define pod resource
specification like how much cpu how much
memory you want this container image to
use
this is where a lot of
cost optimization comes in
because most of the time you will see
unused cpu and memory allocation so just
like easy to think about it like ac2
where you will allocate more
cpu and ram for your ec2
like a select a high tier ec2 even
though you are not using it
so the way to optimize cost and
performance is to detect the cpu and
memory waste from the pod
so how do you do this
so kubernetes you utilize metric server
so once you
install metric server metric server can
tell you how much cpu and memory is
being
utilized in average
uh like it gives you like 10 hours per
day etc
now if you want to
do this manually using all this data
it will be super difficult right
so you should utilize some tools which
gathers this metric server data and then
gives you actionable cost and
performance uh insights
so some of these tools are
cloud watch container insights
so cloudwatch container insights works
with eks
which gets the data and will show you
top 10
memory intensive pods etc and then you
can dive deep and optimize
the cpu memory
specification
some of the other third party tools
cubecast i really like this tool
cubecast you can try it out for free
it actually gives you like the dollar
amount how much you are wasting and
gives you hey if you
reduce this allocation you will save
this much money cloudhealth super
popular third party tool
kubernetes resource report these are the
few popular ones but there are many more
so it's very important for you to
explain to the interviewer that what is
the cost biggest cost component
mention that unused cpu memory and then
go into your thought process that how do
you detect cpu memory using these tools
okay moving on to uh another question so
this is a question where a lot of you
guys and girls probably struggle
uh especially if you haven't worked in a
real world kubernetes app
uh tell me about a challenge you face in
kubernetes
so one thing to keep in mind is um
mention a challenge so mentioning a
challenge
is okay
but important is you also have to answer
how you solved it
right because that's where the
interviewer is trying to see whether you
actually worked on it or not
so i'm going to give you a challenge on
the answer
and then couple of other ideas that you
can mention
so let's say the challenge is
you are running your kubernetes
application on eks let's say you have
hundreds of nodes
and then kubernetes released a new
version so to upgrade your cluster to
new kubernetes version there is a lot
that you have to do
first you have to create and rehydrate
the amis with the new kubernetes version
number two big challenge you face is
while you creating and rehydrating the
amis for the worker nodes
you have to keep your application up and
running
uh
keeping application highly available
while you are doing this and maintaining
pod disruption budget so you can say
that
um
it's like a lot of overhead in your
devops tool chain
uh keeping the same number of pods up
and running while you are draining
so it's one of the challenge you faced
so how did you solve it
you can say that you used eks managed
node group
where aws provided the patched mi so you
do not have to
worry about
patching as soon as possible you don't
have to go create ami all that stuff aws
is in charge of giving you the ami that
you can grab it and apply it
regarding the application part aws
manage node group does that for you as
well
and the while manage node group does
that
application will be up and running with
high availability
it also respects pod disruption budget
you don't have to uh
do all these in your devops tool chain
do this mathematics and all that stuff
and it's one click update uh or
basically one api call right so it makes
your life super easier
there are a couple of other ideas
another challenge that real world
application face is
as your application grows you know in
kubernetes let's say for eks
each pod uses a ip address from your ppc
right so
uh as you grow as your application grows
there is a chance that
with a lot of concurrent
pods running at the same time
you run out of ip address in your vpc
that's one of the challenge
how you solve it is with eks cluster you
can add additional subnet
afterwards even after cluster is defined
so you can mention that as well so
moving on how do you scale your
kubernetes app
so there are two main main ways to scale
your kubernetes app one is horizontal
pod auto scaler
and then next is the cluster auto scaler
where the number of node increases
these two super important i have a
separate video explaining this too
make sure you study those i'm going to
give the link up top
now the third
kind that not a lot of the interviewee
will explain
but this one is used in a real world
application
is cluster over provisioning
so let me explain the challenge with
this hpa and cluster autoscaler
so let's say you have two worker nodes
and your application is running uh
worker node utilization is let's say
like 50 or something
as your application uh
traffic increases
you will spawn more and more pods on in
those two worker nodes right so at some
point these two worker nodes will be
at full capacity
so to scale more
the cluster autoscaler will create
more ec2 worker nodes
but this process takes a little bit of
time right depend on your ami so it has
to grab the mi the ec2 has to come up so
there will be a little bit of latency
what if your application
is
like a super critical low sla
application you cannot afford that kind
of latency
so with a cluster over provisioning
you will bring up
all the ec2 workers up
right so let's say
even though two worker nodes are being
used uh with your real application pods
you bring up hundreds of other easy
tools depending on your application
and for the other worker nodes you run
these fake parts we call them pause pods
and let's say
slowly the first two worker nodes goes
to 100 utilization
and when the traffic increases more
the ec2s are already up and running so
your application
don't need to spend any more time
spinning up additional ec2's all it will
do is replace the pause pods with your
actual application pod
so in case in case of critical launches
low sla
requirement this is used in real world
app
you can actually mention this as well as
your challenge do you face uh in real
world kubernetes app and how you solved
it using cluster over provisioning
okay moving on um
how do you expose a kubernetes micro
service to consumers so basically your
pod is running how can outside world
call it
um
so probably you guys are thinking
services right so you have three kinds
of services in kubernetes uh node port
load balancer and cluster ip
uh if you want to expose
your pod to outside world
load balancer comes to your mind right
where a load balancer will be created it
will have a dns name and then you can
call the dns name it will go call the
pod
so i have a separate video going over
all this as well i'm going to give the
link
however
what the interviewer is looking for is
ingress
because in real world applications you
cannot just use load balancer
because the problem is let's say you
have five micro services
and then you have five load balancer
with different dns names so you have to
put another load balancer on top
so that the padding works like generally
the applications will have a static part
of the
cut domain and then the second part will
change let's say www.example.com
get slash update etc and for each of
these different paths you want it to go
to different microservices
if you just use
separate load balancer service for each
of these
microservice you cannot achieve this
easily
so ingress you can have one load
balancer and for each different path it
can send the traffic
to uh different microservices
so i have a separate video ingress is
super critical in real world app
so it's very very important that you
understand this i have a separate video
on this because this is a detailed topic
as you can see with ingress
with the same
domain path let's say batcave.com
for each of the slash
path it can send to different services
underneath
so yeah i'll give the link of the video
up top
make sure you watch that one and there
are different options for this ingress
part
you can use traffic this is a third
party software that creates ingress for
your kubernetes
you can use engine x ingress controller
if you are using
eks
as your current cluster you can use lb
ingress controller as well this one is
gaining a lot of popularity
so moving on
do you have to use kubernetes to run
your containerized application
so this is kind of like a trick question
the answer is no right
so kubernetes
is
one of the many container orchestrator
so again what is content orchestrator
that comes under kind of basic questions
uh so i'll give it a i'll give a link to
one of my very popular video up top you
can watch it
uh but if you already containerized your
application and as long as uh the
container orchestrator supports the
runtime let's say you use docker as long
as your content orchestrator
supports a runtime that allows you to
run your container image
that's it right
kubernetes gives you functionalities and
kubernetes is the most popular content
orchestrator
but some of the other ways to run your
container image
is amazon elastic container service or
ecs
docker swarm apache missiles etc uh so
yeah kubernetes is not an absolute must
if you just want to run your container
all right guys and girls that's the
video if you find this video useful
please do all the youtube stuff like
this video
subscribe
comment also actually in the comment let
me know if there are other questions
that's in your mind for kubernetes that
you want me to go over
all right guys and girls that's it for
this video i'll see you guys and girls
in the next video bye